so i have two phones i should name them
what can we call them let's call this
one g and let's call this one q
hey what's up gq my name is damson idris
aka the ceo of the dss dart skin society
aka the sexiest man to ever exist sexier
than idris elba brad pitt leonardo
dicaprio combined i actually received
sexiest man alive every year but i
turned it down these are my essential
items i am getting paid by everything
i'm about to promote
[Music]
my first essential item is actually
these glasses i walked in the store and
i was like
i want to be like a black john lennon
i used to buy a lot of expensive glasses
and then i kept losing them when i first
got to la i used to drive a mustang
because that's the car you drive when
you first come to america from london
and i'd put a roof down i thought i was
so cool and then i was on the freeway
and then boom the glasses were just like
and i was like oh my gosh there goes
all my money
so yeah 20 bucks man but they're kind of
cool like i think they're fly what do
you think
[Music]
at number two every
black man's secret
[Music]
this curl sponge my hair is actually
naturally curly i came out the womb like
this but just to add some effect you
know you put a little
little something on there back in the
day i actually used to cut holes into a
sponge like a normal sponge that you'd
like wash dishes with i used to cut
holes into it because that's what all
the barber shops were doing in peckham
and then boom
they just made it like this like two
different sides
and um i don't go anywhere without it
[Music]
soccer ball
yeah i didn't have it anymore
there's something about footballs that
kind of stimulates my mind helps me
learn lines so easily i've broken so
many sculptures in my house when i'm
learning lines i kind of walk around the
house i have a football in my hand and i
just kick it about i always wanted to be
a footballer when i was growing up i
support manchester united the best team
in the entire world listen manchester
united if you want me to play for your
team i would quit acting and come and
play i'd score so many more goals than
ronaldo he's whack
he's not whack
he's not work
uh hell yeah
i'm wearing prada right now but
let's see what happens
i'm not gonna lose my street cred let me
mess up all this lighting
[Music]
oh
and that's why i'm now an actor peace
[Music]
altoids i've only just realized it
actually says curiously strong mints
which is
kind of interesting curiously why is it
curious
i probably have like 20 of these a day
you know we have intimate scenes
sometimes i often work with uh actors
and um of course and
i play characters that are screaming in
people's faces i did this brick by brick
scene and season three while i was
screaming in isaiah john's face i built
this [ __ ]
me
brick by brick and i'll be damn if i let
you tear it down
so um
altoids came in handy they also sound
great
really promoting this altoids i'd like
some free altoids please that's why i
brought this here
[Music]
this black vest
i probably have like a hundred of them
i'm actually wearing one right now i did
a campaign with calvin klein uh sorry i
dropped the name on the floor there she
pick out for me please um
i did a campaign with calvin i stole a
bunch of best no one knows shh they're
probably gonna find out now if i'm not
wearing whatever my characters wear i'm
probably wearing this i'm not one of
those celebrities who like
wears a different outfit every day like
that's crazy
did i just call myself a celebrity i'm a
normal guy and you're probably gonna see
this jacket again in some other
interview okay i always read like the
first 10 comments on my grammar whatever
and this girl was like oh he's wearing
that jacket again i was like
oh yeah
what am i supposed to do to give it to
my nephew
anyway
i love this vest
[Music]
yeah
oh man look at that
this little guy right here
this is called rob lipo
it's actually nigerian
and it's one of those things you know
every culture has that thing that your
mom like makes you put on everything
like if you have a flu like put some rob
on it like where my mom's case you'll be
like put on rub on it she's the one who
introduced me to this and she's always
like do you want some rob and i'm like
yes mama
and i take it everywhere with me
next is my saxophone
her name's sheila i named her after one
of my cast mates wigs on snowfall i fell
in love with the saxophone sound when i
fell in love with chad
they would always play these amazing sex
moments in the songs and then fella
couti would of course play the baritone
but i got an alto because
i'm not as good as fella cootie of
course nowhere near i'm so bad at
playing instruments right
that when i was in school i had music
class obviously and you had to play an
instrument to get a grade and i was so
bad that the teacher was just like
uh dancing just sing
[Music]
[Music]
i'm still learning my aim was to learn
them it's beginning to look a lot like
christmas i kind of just got to this bit
um so i'm nearly there
[Music]
so i have two phones and one's pleasure
in one's business
you know as an actor you're alone so
much you know you're alone on a plane
alone in the back of a car and this
connects me to the world connects me to
my family who i love when did you
uh decided i didn't want people taking
my number so so here's the thing right
we should talk about this i feel like
when you meet someone right and like you
like them and it's like cool and you
like don't don't ask them for their
number i think give give them your
number and like give them the
opportunity to call you so i have two
numbers this one is for the people i
really [ __ ] with and then and then this
one um if you ever ask me for my number
and i give you i give you this this
bigger phone
that one
that one
you know what time it is
[Music]
oh
hey baby how you doing
how you doing you look looking real
pretty today you know
so uh this is my wife my playstation 5
has ruined the majority of my
relationships i play
fifa ultimate team but more than
anything
i play call of duty rebirth island with
my friends we're on headset screaming
always with the same group man naira and
jamil lewis tossing collar sam
sam doesn't play because he's a father
of 15. i've known those guys since since
primary school man i've known them since
i was 11 years old
[Music]
so in the last fifa ea like sent me like
pele ronaldinho and maradona oh i
shouldn't i shouldn't say that
yeah celebrities are cheating on
ultimate team by the way bombshell we
get free cards okay ha ha
that's why you keep losing
this guy right here
it was recommended to me by a makeup
artist she was like oh uh dancing
there's this amazing product uh you
should definitely use it and make your
skin look all glowy and nice and
everything and kevin hart uses it and
i'm like but kevin hart ain't got glowy
um skin i'm playing i love kev love kev
it's called lumet i've been using it
ever since i've been using it for years
if any of you want to have skin that's
like
[Music]
use the mare
[Music]
the real thing that matters to me is
this woman right here
my mama this was on her 70th birthday
she looks so pretty
she's my most valuable
essential item
when i'm with her i just feel safe she's
like my safety net everything i do i do
in her honor i'm the youngest of six and
uh uncle to
16 nieces and nephews i'm now a great
uncle actually and my mom is at the head
of that empire and hopefully i could
bring that big nigerian family here la's
definitely going to be a lot louder when
they arrive
so
these are my essential items thank you
so much for tuning in
dancing idris
[Music]
over and out